si tu me dis
Cyril tu bluffes je balance tout
si tu me dis Cyril
je sais que tu sais
je dis rien rien
qui
toi Cyril puis-je donner ma
réponse je suis un homme courageux je
sais que tu sais
alors la vérité vous savez que je peux
faire ça avec tous les chroniqueurs
d'ailleurs je vais le faire
Guillaume chanton et tu le sais j'ai des
énormes dossiers sur toi
je pense que toi ça peut durer une
seconde
où tu me dis je bluff ou tu me dis je
sais que tu sais
je sais que tu sais et tu sais que je
sais et que je sais que tu sais que je
sais
les menaces
tu sais que je sais que tu sais que je
sais
[Applaudissements]
je sais que tu sais
que pour toi ça n'a rien à voir et tu
parles que pour ta personne on appelle
ça l'équilibre de la terreur pour
l'ensemble des équipes c'est à dire vous
et moi alors je vais t'expliquer
quelque chose moi
alors
de chemin oui tu retires tout de suite
de balancer des gros dossiers sur toi
c'est très simple tu vas voir deux
chemins c'est pas pareil franchement
dépassé ma pensée
et c'est ce qu'on peut tous balancer des
choses mais je pense que voilà je pense
que ça sera plus compliqué pour ta
personne
étant donné ce que je sais
[Rires]
je te laisse vas-y fais comme si il
rentre pas franchement
moi je suis un bonhomme j'en ai rien à
et je vais retirer les menaces
Guillaume
c'est très bien dit
mais est-ce que en fait c'est trop long
on aurait pas le temps
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout merci
alors je sais que vous savez tout
donc vous savez tout
fin de la question
on passe à quelqu'un d'autre
[Rires]
je suis le sur un pilier moi il y a pas
un peu de toute cette équipe
parce que Guillaume on est en couverture
alternée
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez savoir
moi je dis tout hein en direct
posez votre question c'est quoi votre
question c'était quoi est-ce que
je peux balancer des dossiers sur vous
c'était pas c'était pas ça qu'ils ont eu
comme question
est-ce que vous pensez que je bloque mon
prêt c'était ça ou est-ce que vous savez
vous allez dire Siri non je sais que tu
sais c'est bon moi je suis le plus
courageux ici j'espère que personne moi
mais je sais que tu sais
[Applaudissements]
mais oui c'est fou ça
il va bien alors moi j'ai très envie de
faire pipi
à l'avance tu as pas vu
mais pourquoi tu te mets derrière pour
faire pipi connard
tu es très envie de faire pipi je mets
franchement ça se voit je pense que
il le savent les quatre voilà ils savent
que c'est plutôt compliqué ils savent
que voilà